tim cook
goes out there and uses one word in his
speech
one word in a speech that made apple 103
billion dollars
by just dropping one word kyle do you
want to bring up that picture
so tim cook gets up there and says
we may come out with a
apple car they have not sold a single
car
but they made 103 billion dollars
without having sold a single car
do you think apple can compete in the
car market
i don't think so in terms of
manufacturing it going through all that
headache
but i think that the apple experience i
think if apple
went to someone like a ford
and says hey you build it but it's the
apple experience and
and it's all that great connection
between hardware and software
because remember the apple phone unlike
android the apple phone they control the
hardware and the software and they make
it work together so beautifully
i think if they do that with one of the
big manufacturers
i think it's a player i think it's very
very real i'll have to disagree with tom
here
i think if they i think if they decide
they want to get into cars they're going
to do it and they're going to do it very
well
they have a couple advantages i mean
it's it's the same analogy with the
phone if someone said hey do you think
they could have a great phone down the
road and
who knew that they were already working
on it for five years they have the
ability to go hire anybody they want why
can't they go get the best people at
tesla
the very very best in the world get them
and steal the secrets and
and just do it a little bit better plus
you automatically coming out of the gate
thinking that whatever apple designs is
going to be cutting edge
different cool out of the box gotta have
it
you know latest bells and whistles the
whole thing so ah man i think they're
right there
now they might be a little aggressive
with 2024 you know maybe that's a little
bit
sooner than realistically being able to
roll these off the assembly line but man
i'm kind of excited to think what they
can do
making cars i think it's going to be
spectacular here's what elon musk said
about it on december 22nd
during the darkest days of the model 3
program i reached out to tim cook
to discuss the possibility of apple
acquiring tesla
for one tenth of our current value which
means around 60 billion
okay give or take he refused to take the
meeting
strange if true tesla already uses iron
phosphate for medium-range cars made in
shanghai factory a
a monocellus electron electrochemically
impossible as
max voltage is 100 times too low maybe
they meant
cells bonded together like our
structural battery pack
so i don't know whether that was a shot
being taken or not but if he's
responding to it
there's only one reason you would
respond if you actually think apple
could be
a threat if you respond right now you
know for me
by the way i'll read you what they said
in the reports here a closely watched
apple analyst
is warning that investors should be
cautious about a report that an iphone
maker
is planning to produce a self-driving
car in 2024 last week's report by
reuters
since shares of companies that build
parts of an uh autonomous
uh uh cars like litter
centers how do you pronounce that word
l-i-d-a-r lidar
lidar centers sensors soaring but but
the hype was purely on speculation
some of those companies might supply
parts of the apple car tfi analyst
ming chi kuo warned in a note this
weekend we believe that the current
so-called apple car concept stocks are
only speculations by the market and do
not involve
apple actual apple car suppliers
we also think that because ev
self-driving car technical specs are
still evolving
it is too early to talk about the final
specs of the apple car
the part of this conversation has taken
place is that
tim wants to have one big bang before
leaving
like he's getting to a point where he's
thinking about you know maybe
i've done my part my season's coming to
an end and i want to kind of leave with
a splash and it's
i come out with the apple car like i
would love to see
elon i had this conversation the other
day with um uh
uh uh mkbhd youtube channel 30 million
subscribers phenomenal conversation with
them
and i said what do you think are the
chances of tesla
elon musk going into the phone business
and winning
so question for both of you guys here
what's more likely to be successful
for elon musk to say screw you tim cook
i'm going to go into the phone business
and take market share away from you and
i'm going to create a tesla phone
is elon musk more capable of competing
in the phone business and smartphone
or is apple more capable of competing in
the car business what do you think
apple's more capable of completing the
car business
absolutely you know if elon puts his
head to it he can battery remember he
can say battery this iphone this
computer
a phone that i created tesla the battery
life lasts a week
true true i'm looking at the
entanglements on
on the phone i i the phone is like seven
subsystems
batteries only one of them you know you
there are so many things that go into a
phone as well as the community
and the whole application development
environment that took three years
just to develop that it is so much
easier
for apple to take experiential
programming and usage
and brand and put it around and you know
i i think it's far easier for apple to
make a car with the right partner than
it's going to be for elon musk to
make a phone complete opposite i think
it'd be way easier for elon musk to do a
tesla phone because he's already proven
he can do a tesla tequila
and anything else he wants to the other
thing too is drinking and driving
he'd be able to hurt apple quicker
well that's a good idea drinking and
driving because it's a self-driving car
and you can drink and use the holder for
it yes but you were saying no no
when you drink give your car the keys
yeah i really think no
if he wanted to i mean look he's
building a tunnel to lax from hawthorne
i mean good god
and that gets no publicity or what he's
doing in vegas the guy can do anything
he wants
and set his mind to it plus he could be
a little nat nipping at apple and
stealing you know five percent of their
phone share which make a huge difference
to them
and it's easy i think you could produce
a phone quicker so yeah i think he could
do that by the way i am so against
self-driving cars i don't want to know
that the car next to me on the 405
is self-driving really tell me why
because it just scares me
i i don't trust self-driving cars at all
i trust self-driving planes
self-flying yes but there's less traffic
in the air
the less traffic in the air and you know
what there's not idiot
pilots next to him you know flanking him
all over
making illegal turns in front of him but
yes i do trust
sell flying planes more than i trust
pilots to be honest with you but the
self-driving cars i cannot wrap my arms
around it i know people that go to work
without basically driving it's all
programmed
what about if you have road rage is that
programmed into it where the car will
actually flip the other guy
hit the guy so so you're saying apple
is more likely to get into the car
business and succeed then elon musk
is likely to get into the phone business
and succeed yeah other tom makes good
points but i'm
i'm sticking with my point here's the
other thing musk is petty he'd do it
i know he would do it i know he would do
it yeah um
succeed keyword is succeed not just get
into it
it's to succeed who do you bet on i
think making a phone
just seems easier than making a car all
the parts so you think
tesla more than apple think so
unfortunately i have to go to
with tesla so tesla would have a better
shot you're thinking tesla or apple i'm
kind of rooting for tesla but i think
apple has a really good shot strictly
because growing up i always wondered you
know what if apple came out with their
own tv what if apple came out with their
own car
no one really thinks what if tesla came
out with their own can you imagine like
you drive an apple car
apple car you know what do you have the
latest apple car i mean
you got it that car has got to look
pretty cool it's got to look different
it's got to be
they're not going to make a product that
doesn't look right you might get a free
laptop with it too
because i'm actually being paid so i
like your point too of that tim cook
might want to have some sort of legacy
play here because if he retires what's
he going to be known for
he developed a great stock price for
apple there's nothing sexy
about his legacy and he bought a few
companies right and not to say that he's
on steve jobs level but you still want
to be remembered for something
especially when competing against
car if he does the car and the car does
stuff it's
it's uh it's going to be interesting for
those of you guys that are watching this
what what do you think is more
likelihood of happening
elon musk competing in a marketplace
with phones or tim cook and apple
competing in the marketplace with cars
by the way
another question for you right now
tesla's worth what 600 billion
do you think tesla in 2021 will cross a
trillion
i think it's yes i think it's maybe it's
not 21
or maybe it's early 22 but i think they
will be the next one in the tea club
so you're putting them to cross it so
you're saying wells fargo has no clue
what the hell they're talking about
i'm i'm not going to
debate the wells fargo article i'm
looking at where
elon musk is going with energy people
forget that tesla is at its heart not on
automotive outcomes
energy wells fargo article is important
they're saying tesla's the next aol
you're saying tesla's going to be the
next trillion dollar that is an argument
so do you think tesla you think wells
fargo is way off
with their assessment of tesla way off
okay
so you think they'll be a trillion
dollar company uh not in 2021 okay but i
think they eventually will be and have
we ruled out the fact that
dude have we ruled out the fact that he
could go the route of alphabet like
google has and put everything under one
umbrella is that impossible
i think if he does that he will he
probably won't do that because he knows
a biden
administration will try to break it
apart okay so he's going to be better
off just separating all of them so he
doesn't have to deal with the politics
do you agree with that tomorrow
he wouldn't put everything under one
company i i completely agree with that
right now with the attitude in
washington i think any smart ceo is
going to say hang on
let's
were you going to say moreover no
i think it's like let's have some more
stuff
hey by the way pat i mentioned this
earlier did you know that elon musk flew
to hawaii to go meet with larry ellison
what is that all about i don't know
there's got to be some strategic thing
behind it
no i'll tell you but if if i was going
to go get advice and regulated and
if i thought i was in trouble i thought
i needed strategic advice on a macro
scale
i go talk to larry ellison you know
oracle and larry ellison
they are the lord god king of
lobbying against their competitors and
working with the senate and congress for
legislation
that helps oracle and doesn't help other
people so if i was going to go
get advice or work with people or look
at um
you know look at financing larry
everybody forgets
what number is larry ellison look he's
right up there 20 something
in the teens how about how about number
four or five or six larry ellison is
usually top ten
four five or six i like the way you're
thinking because your my first thought
was
who hates apple does larry ellison hate
apples but not really
i mean there isn't this direct
competitive thing there so maybe the
lobbying issue
where he stays a step ahead of it three
four five years down the road
tapping into some of that expertise that
he might have elon musk is not dumb and
larry ellison would be a great
private mentor and when i mean private
mentor i mean talking about things at
nine levels up you know what i mean plus
he could probably sell him a lot of
tequila i mean you gotta run up the
american party
elon musk tweets out saying just
meeting with larry ellison to seek some
advice back working on tesla end of
quarter tomorrow
december 28 2020
he tweets that out i mean you got to
realize he's
sending a message to somebody hey that
tweet is probably only for one person
correct and no one knows who that one
person is okay you know pat at
vtpost.com you know you can kind of get
a good gauge on what
what's driving the world what people are
interested in there isn't a day
that goes by where i'm not picking an
elon musk story he's relevant every
single day
with something he does or at least
interesting he's at least interesting
and if you're going to go visit larry
ellison the nice thing about hawaii you
can say larry i'm going to bring my
pr person my security detail my entire
family do you have space
you know it's like i own the island of
lanai great so you have space
so you can have private conversations
with larry and there's just a lot of
space stop for the two percent you said
right yeah two percent he owns 98 not
but there's two percent
state apparently it's emergency services
and basic
you know what he paid for it do you know
the number what he paid for it was it
was pretty it was like 100 million it
wasn't much
i thought i thought it was 700. i
thought it was well it was like it was
literally
yeah what was it it's nothing it's less
than you would think for on hawaiian
island you know who else bought a ton of
property out there
isn't it zuckerberg wasn't he buying a
ton in hawaii too well
he bought a plantation for himself out
there
and that's a little south of island but
um it's uh
it's something so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye